go live
okay for people joining this live stream
we are going over
some features that are heading for
version 12.3
of language um and this is a variety of
things
dates astronomy geography
oh boy there's a lot of things here all
right where are we starting
date and time extensively improve
parsing and formatting of dates yeah
have you made that really fast now
yeah we've been working on a handful of
you know low hanging fruit improvements
and then some structural improvements to
make
our calls into the library more
efficient to trim out some of the fat
so that's a process that's ongoing um
but we wanted to also focus
a bit today on some of the feature
editions that we've talked about in the
past and that we've added in
um okay all right so let's take a look
here so should i look at these
from date string as one place to
document date strings
yeah so this isn't necessarily new
functionality we've had functionality
that takes
date strings and turns them into date
objects but
we're it gives us a place to collect a
lot of documentation about how
you input date strings into one specific
location and gives us sort of a
canonical
this is how you handle in dates in
different formats
um it also mirrors the syntax of
date string so we have the string and
then
the format as a second argument rather
than the old form which is a single
argument that is a list of the string
and then a list of format elements
uh that's always a little complicated to
look at so yeah wait a minute wait a
minute so this is
equivalent to if i say date object of
one of these strings i will get the same
result
typically as data object or from date
string of that string is that correct
or yeah from date string by default
returns a data object
so yeah you'll get the same result in
both cases this is just
rather than having a giant subsection in
data object of this is how we handle all
of these arguments and
if it's it's a little weird it's a
little weird
well we have a parallel in from absolute
time
is another case where you know we you
can just give an absolute time to date
object
and it will return an absolute time but
we also want to kind of migrate away
from the the standard notation
being that you know you can slap any
date form into a date object and you
don't necessarily know exactly
what it represents you know
okay but does all of this stuff
supported also in date object or not
yeah so we're we're migrating in but the
syntax is a little different because
you need to have an extra list around
the input what are you talking about in
which case
in inside date object if you say this is
a here's a string it's a date we'll
parse it
if you say here is a string that is a
date and
this is the format the specification you
have to use is to add an extra list
around there because they need to be
collected into the first argument of
date object which is
what are the format elements for the for
date object for that
yeah so everything that's supported in
from date string
is also supported inside date object
itself so i
am okay i think the second argument here
it feels a lot more natural than in date
object so one doesn't think of adding
this additional list with formats
while here i agree it's the second
argument that feels very natural
yeah i agree this is a better design
maybe we should de-document
the um the extra sort of tentacles for
date object
yeah we were hoping to kind of point the
i've got a date string i want to turn it
into a date functionality to
be this from date string as a landing
page because otherwise
you know we accept that input anywhere
you can put a date in in the language
but having to document it in the dozens
of functions that take data inputs
is kind of cumbersome okay but but
you're saying
that the format where you give a string
version of a date in a list
with other interpretational elements
is something that we support and i'm
saying maybe we shouldn't maybe we
should just de-document that
and if you want to do it with these
additional elements use form date string
we certainly could go that direction i
think you know certainly for the first
version we should
support both of them but we could deduct
we should go on supporting it we can go
on supporting it
but i think we should de-document it
because i think it's confusing and that
way
all of the complicated processing as
you've described as in from date stream
okay yeah i mean it's definitely a
common user input error we get
from customers when they're confused
about why didn't this
understand the date format it's because
the syntax is a little cumbersome
so i think yeah promoting this and
de-emphasizing the old forms makes sense
right i think that's i think we should
de-document
the date object of anything other than a
pure string
and we should say if you want to
make it a non-default string used from
date string
okay i like that okay i need to
okay you went farther than i thought you
would
the but it's only because i think it's a
mess i mean i think the previous version
is a mess
i do okay but you don't always see that
so
why does this have to be in a list here
uh well right now it's it's in a list
there because
the elements framework usually wants it
as a list
you should be able to specify it as just
a single element too like that will be
supported but okay
so how does this relate to what we've
had previously in date string
so in date string this new association
spec
is basically fleshing out what we've had
in date string beforehand
um what we basically want to be able to
do
is the second argument of date string
was typically just
what this elements argument in the
association is
there's a whole bunch of different
elements you could potentially have
and what we've done is in addition to
the existing just list a bunch of
formats you want or put whatever
delimiters you want in between them
we've sort of formalized the arguments
in a format to say these are the
elements i want
this is potentially the language i want
it in if there's a variation in writing
script i may also want those elements in
this writing script
i want these delimiters inserted between
elements i thought we had a language
option
just a straight top-level language
option for this
um in other places but not in in dates
yeah not in dates so that's
one of the new editions that we've added
in okay but rather than having a
symbol named language option you're
putting the language in the state string
association right right the language
here
is a part of the format specification
together with other things
so having it as a symbol would make it
too important in comparison
yeah okay
and it could be perhaps supported as a
symbol just in case it's the only thing
that you're right and
you feel like yes using the symbol
yeah we could certainly why not there's
a fair bit of precedence for if you just
provide a rule in a place that an
association could be
it's the same thing
all right these are all default date
strings
yeah so they're using the default date
string format and then
it is using the language and locale
that you provide here so the now you're
also using default
date stream if i said if i said here
if i said yesterday
i don't understand that why didn't that
work
what is the day that this
prototype build was from
um i don't know but hold on a second
concatenates the specified elements in
the order given
okay yesterday that seems to be
something that
broke just yes can you try now
exactly okay set it uh try a date list
instead
something got messed up with a hook and
date object on there
really really
really oh it's a time zone
what happened there
i can't read chinese but i can tell
that's not to that that's not january
1st 2000.
yeah why is that switching the timezone
over
so it's probably using the
uh so what so in input
our time zone and an output their time
sum or something like that
something is very wrong here yeah that's
a configuration issue
with the call into the library if you
add
an a fourth element to that date list of
one does it yeah i know i was i was you
know
i'm sorry i was just my my truffle
finder for bugs
caused me to do this it's
it's quite uncanny really
yeah so it's something in a time zone
adjustment that's
well something's wrong though yeah yeah
that's something i'll look into
after this okay
okay the general idea here is with the
language specification
we allow entities obviously language
locales
and then there are some standard uh
language codes for
the uh iso standards have prescribed so
you know it when it's a language option
it's pretty obvious how we would
interpret any of those
uh okay the next section is that you can
specify a language or a locale
as how do you
puerto rican
spanish is that going to be understood
splaff
what's the what are the linguistics like
for some for puerto rico
spanish language local no
we have not exposed yet the linguistics
for these
entities okay but we should
sure okay
okay local dependent formats
so we've had a handful of formats in the
past
date time date time short iso dates that
have
prescribed elements and orders
associated with them
but in a lot of cases for locale
dependent dates the order of
elements and exactly which elements show
up
changes country to country and language
to language and so
these are the new uh
proposed names and proposed collections
of
compact dates called medium
long and full dates that basically show
either the compact forms are generally
just the numeric elements for dates
and what are these before what were
these before so these didn't actually
exist before
um we had we got dates short on things
but that was basically it we didn't have
anything it was basically
you know whether we show the full
day of week and full month name or the
abbreviated forms of them
and so here there's a difference between
the
medium and long forms include month but
not
day of week typically
and the variation between medium and
long is whether it's an abbreviated
month name or long
what about date short what happened the
date short so date short is still there
um in this case i didn't so the date
compact here
is just showing the new versions so you
could put date short in that same list
and it would
okay but what was date short do relative
to date media
so date short will do
effectively so it will
add in the short form of the day of week
yeah so this is not a good sequence yeah
not a good sequence
so yeah these are tentative names that
we need
it's not a good sequence because date
short is longer than date medium which
is
not wrong yeah right
right but something that it's important
in these new formats is that they
depend on the on the language also
because
they shortest is defined as a fixed
order of these
elements always but these new ones are
depend on the on the local
okay so
i mean it's kind of date
okay so full date is full date
right which is your date full right
yeah yeah we could basically invert the
argument order and say
you know this is short date medium date
long date full date
but there's still the dissonance between
date short
is longer than what's typical
okay first question is do we want to
keep date
i think we want date short because i
think we're otherwise because we want
months short and all these other ones
short
okay so i think we just need to rename
you know
date for date full is just fine
okay so now
um well
look i think time should probably be
this one i don't know whether that's
already defined
it is times the time zone typically
okay well then we should leave it that
way so what where's the analogous thing
for time
um okay but anyway so so let's go back
to date
so we've got so perhaps the the
important thing here is the fact that
it contains the day of the week yes but
wait wait you're wait wait is that that
that's we've called day name elsewhere
right
um so
take time short
time so date
time there's
there's presumably a date time full
that includes the time zone yeah so that
would you'd have to scroll slightly in
your
left hand notebook but okay but then
date time full and probably date time
short full
maybe we should just be explicit date
time time
date time time zone doesn't work
um
let's try date time full here
okay okay so let's go back to the other
one now have we had 3 9
21 before have we had is that a format
we've had
it's not a preset format that we've had
before now
okay that's good for what but i mean um
what should we call it is is there a
standard name for it in the dating
so to speak literature it's typically
called the short date
at least within icu and the the unicode
standards
um we could call it date numeric because
it's typically defined by being just
numeric elements
there's no month names no
day of week i don't think that's
terrible
i mean let's see date
i don't like it actually i think i think
date
digits might be better or something
date no names
i'm not sure um let's think about this
that will be confusing for
for languages like japanese or chinese
where anyway
there is no name well they use like the
number of the month always
i see all right so date compact
yeah i don't like that very much
date minimal
i mean our normal name sizes are tiny
small medium and large
yeah but we already blew that because
we've already got small
yeah short
what are you saying you're saying tiny
small
medium and large
we didn't use small
that's really confusing though to have a
date short and a date small
all right we've got the full date which
we're calling date
the short date which is just shortening
the words
and detail i'm sorry
detail special
for just the numbers
maybe okay date short as that now we've
also got to have dates short
okay we've got the full thing with the
day of week
no date short
okay this is the shortened version
okay so what we're calling date
the full date is day of week
and month and date short is the
shortened
name for both of those
and then we have two new formats that
are
without the day of week
i mean this is what it is date without
day name
[Music]
and date without day name short
if we called it date without day name we
at least
understand what it was
but we will keep also this date full
we know the date no just because
because that's different from our
current date
why
can it be yeah so
if if you scroll down on the notebook
there's some examples of element orders
change in date full between different
languages and locales but
the existing
date that we have and have had in
wolfram language always has the elements
in the same order
no matter what
i'm sorry so you're saying you want to
put a different
date thing that allows the order to
change in different locales
yes so basically these four that are in
that list
are ones that are locale dependent we
could say
their date locale short medium long
and full if we wanted
or just local date yeah for the full one
well no i then we could if we if we
called it local
date
we could have the whole sequence yeah
and then we could leave our existing
ones date and date short
that's probably a cleaner solution all
right so then this would be
local date compact
or short now look i think we should say
compact
as edmund is pointing out on our live
stream it's also compacting the year
right it's using a two-digit year in
most cases
right that also depends on the local by
the way
okay so fine so it's local date
um
is that compatible with short then the
next one
that's compatible with this use of short
right it's compatible since it's using a
short one's name
okay then the next one up
is local date
march 9th that's when we don't have
right yeah that's something we don't
have we could call it locale
date or locality medium
i don't think we should call it a call
date because i think that's confusing
with the other one being
okay
is it right to call it without day name
or is that not correct
oh wait i've got it wrong even anyway no
that's
local date but it is without date name
yeah and then that's in the short one
don't have day names
i hate using the word medium it just
somehow is kind of weird
could it be just plain locale date no
it's not consistent with the
full date from date over here
i see right
i i think it's fine if we skip meet him
well i understand but is it okay to call
this long
march 9 2021. it's using the long name
all right well that's what i'm
suggesting okay
okay uh
also for the times we will need that yes
we will
yep so we can use the same same system
yeah you know we have to fix these
stupid greek fonts
where it's grabbing greek letters from
the uh symbol font there for everything
that doesn't accented
okay let's keep going
yeah and so this is the formula
basically takes the same thing
and then from date stream we already
talked about but takes the same
arguments and all right we can interpret
those inputs okay do i need to save this
file or do you have what
we just worked out yeah i have all the
notes okay
all right fine okay good stuff all right
on to the next thing
do we want to look at any of the pages
this format or something like that
uh yeah so date format new
basically it's just formalizing what we
talked about with the
the new elements framework allowing
association specs and allowing you to
spell by the way having a sample i mean
as we did in that other documentation is
really quite important just going down
and
showing samples of all of them yeah so
these tentative ones
we're having tim work on a more clean
version with
sort of a basic example of what we're
going for
right okay
ethan is asking about what about souls
on mars
what sorry what about souls on
mars the planet
i sorry i don't get the first word souls
souls
sols the the analog of days
oh oh i see i see sorry
um yeah the mars rover is quoting them
all the time these days
i see
well once we have a time system adapted
to mars we can do that
but we don't yet have that well
hopefully we'll be ready for the next
landers yes
it'll be ready one thing we can be
pretty sure obviously ready before there
are any humans on mars
i think so um
you know kafir is asking things about
universe model data which i
think is not the right group necessarily
and we're definitely talking about time
scales much shorter than that
um but
let's pass on those comments
probably it's not very hard to update
that we haven't looked at in a while
okay let's keep going
uh what are we looking at next here
enter the language locale we already
talked about
time zone offset oh yeah there's a
there's a one note edition
uh about leap hours yep about leap hours
that you can list
possible time zone offsets for a given
date
so we're working on integrating that
into the language handling for date
object
but there's a new
new usage message or not usage line for
you can list possible time zone offsets
at a given time for a given
time zone input
right so sometimes it's returning just a
single number and sometimes it's
returning a list
it's only returning a list if you use
the two argument form which
previously wasn't used for
so this yeah this final section here we
didn't have a
this is the time zone and this is the
date in that time zone
what are the possible offsets syntax and
that was what we added
okay so we wanted a way to report to the
user
whether we are during a transition
so if you had if you ran this for a
couple days ago when we
started daylight time there's a one-hour
period that doesn't actually exist in
local time
and so let's say there what do we do in
that case if you type that in what do
you do
if you type in if you typed in uh
you know 2 15 a.m
[Music]
so what does it do so what we're working
on adding in now is that it will
give you a warning message and we can
basically
normalize out to moving ahead an
hour as we do indeed you know it's the
same thing if you said
it's february 31st we'd move on to
march whatever but we could give a
warning in the case that you're
entering a time during daylight saving
transition
fair enough fair enough
what's the specified base time zone so
that is you can
you can say what is the time zone offset
between two different time zones
so i want to know the difference between
my time zone and
tokyo's time zone instead of my time
zone and gmt
and what happens if you're in a
transition if two countries are
transitioning today like savings time
at the same time
so that's part of the reason we don't
have so
the two argument form where you provide
a date is always relative to gmt
because if you run into that scenario
where comparing two different
time zones at a specific local time
it does potentially get complicated
where there's a number of permutations
of possible
time zone offsets so right now the two
argument form where you say this is the
time zone
and this is the date i want all possible
time zone offsets are always relative to
gmt
i see but what about that last case that
you give
time zone based date yeah so in that
case
we're basically resolving using the
when you specify that date that date
will intrinsically have
an absolute time in gmt that it's being
measured against if you're doing it
during a time zone transition
it will normalize to the appropriate
form or you'd say i want this to be the
leap variant
hour where we fell back
in november and this is the second 1 30
in the morning
i think it's really weird that the
second argument if it's a date
gives you a list as output
yeah yes we thought about that
this was a way of saving having another
function because if we don't put it in
this function
this needs to be reported through a
separate function
we could do that hold on hold on i'm
thinking
or alternatively having the return
argument
change based on the time you put in
it would be a little strange if it no no
no
no that will just lead to bugs right it
has to be structural
it's like a clock that's right twice a
day or something
this will be a bug that happens twice a
year yeah
it has to be something that you can
detect structurally yeah
that's why i'm a little bit concerned
about the two argument form when it's a
base there
has the same signature in effect
yes so we do this type of thing in in
you know some position and you can give
a date or a
geoposition yes what to do this type of
clear all right okay structural thing
okay fair enough
okay all right let's move on
astro okay so that's for me um
yes so we are starting this project and
we are not as advanced as i was hoping
to be by this point
so for example we have solar time we
have updated sidereal time
and we have the orientation data but the
astroposition
it's here to discuss the design but i
don't think i
will be able to have it for uh 12 3.
so the idea is is in 13 to have astro
position
and astro graphics together
okay so astro
right ascension declination in degrees
yes
right so this this follows the
opposition and having the fourth
argument
given that time is a lot more important
than distance
here uh now time becomes the third
argument
rather than the fourth
alternatively it could be the first but
that's perhaps too important
ethan comments that he's in the lesser
antilles at the moment okay
interesting cool
which doesn't have daylight savings i
think daylight savings is a largely
political decision isn't it
in different countries it's some
in england occasionally they would it
was supposed to be abandoned in europe
this last year but cobit happened
really they were going to give up on it
yes
so it's probably coming back as soon as
things are getting
why did they cut why did they not do it
because of covet
because they had a lot of other things
to deal with i say
i've heard that there are discussions
mostly about
which is the one we are going to choose
and they have asked people about whether
they want winter time and summer time
and people tend to say
tend to say summer time because it
sounds nicer did see that most countries
that do transition off basically
transition onto daylight time and never
come off
which seems a bit counterintuitive who
does what
so most countries when they stop
observing daylight saving time they
transition
on to daylight time and then just never
come off it
rather than going to what is quote
unquote standard time
again because it's winter summer
differences
but you know when i was a kid in england
there was some political party i don't
know for some reason decided on double
summer time
one year i don't know japan talked about
that this past year because summer was
so hot they were going to have
daylight time be two hours in advance to
try and throw off
evening commutes into a cooler time
period
it's so weird okay
well we just have to be on top of these
things which i guess are just curation
issues
right of changes that get made yeah yeah
we use a standard
time zone database for managing these
things same
reference that basically everyone pulls
from
right all that has to happen is somebody
sort of corrupts that database and the
whole world will be showing up an hour
late
um
all remote geo positions be taken into
account properly i'm not sure what that
means
um sorry what where are you oh from
ethan on the live stream will remove
geo positions be taken into account
properly not sure what that means
let's okay so let's just look at astral
position for a bit
presents an event in space a distance r
from the center of the earth
coordinate frame right so here there are
two additional arguments one is the
coordinate frame
which we can think as a set of three
axes plus a clock
and then the coordinate system which
will say how to extract
the numbers from those axes and the
coordinate system can be cylindrical
spherical typically spherical
and is there a relativistic piece to
this or not since you've got
distance when is that time
where is that time that
time is the time as measured by the
coordinate system at the center right
and this
this coordinate system can be inferred
from the center
like doing synchronization of light rays
sent back and forth or something like
that
but so that t refers to the center of
the earth
yes exactly
and then uh yes the center of the earth
or if we have another frame we could
have a frame which is centered at the
sun for example and then d
would be time for the sun
oh i see so this is a coordinate frame
which is the analog
it's not a projection really it's an
actual coordinate frame
right so you can think more of the frame
as the datum and the coordinate system
as the projection
yes the coordinate system is just pure
geometry there's no physics there but
the frame has the
the physics it's telling you where you
are
and uh yeah it takes into account the
change of
speed of one moving with respect to the
other this type of thing
how does it take account of that i mean
i don't understand the the
frame so for example
when you go from the earth to the sun
and you have to change the time you have
to take into account the conversions of
time take into account the fact that one
is moving with respect to the other so
there's okay
yeah i get it okay so given a frame okay
so where are some frames possible frames
include
the galactic frame the supergalactic
frame
oh boy hey how about for the freaking
universe we know roughly where the
center of the universe is
do we know it accurately enough to be
able to use it as a frame
what do you mean the center of the
universe
the point at which we are expanding from
i don't think there is such a concept
well there's a cosm
there's a rest frame of the cosmic
microwave background
there's the center of mass of the cosmic
microwave background
well yes which means there is a
preferred velocity but not a preferred
position
so we can we can check that we we are
moving with respect to that
preferred frame but there is no
preferred point in the universe that we
could call the center
or all points are moving with respect to
any other point
yeah fair point
okay i mean this was the question of of
frames we're not going to deal with
frames at other stages in the history of
the universe yet
no no these are this this is mostly
to change in the solar system or to the
galactic
frame which are there
yeah so the important things here is the
ssb is the solar system body center
we could have another one centered at
the sun which is not the same thing
because the sun
the solar system by the center is just
outside the sun
what about for for um you know
uh galaxy um
surveys and so on what coordinate system
they use are they just using
what are they using um
well the they can be the equatorial
frame is the most important ones right
this is the fundamental so that's why
when we don't give any frame by default
is the equatorial one
i see and and then
uh yeah it depends catalogs things that
are related to the galaxy
may typically use the galactic
coordinate frame but the galactic
coordinate frame is a bit confusing
because it's centered
at the at the solar system very center
so not at the center of the galaxy
i see so it's a bit confusing
okay so then we also have time markers
exactly so the specification of the
frame
needs this time system which is the
thing i was planning to start with
which is propagating all this stuff
through date object but but
it we haven't done it yet it's the very
next step
okay and so can the user specify a frame
the general i mean there are some famous
frames which are the ones that
are typically used then the last line
will allow you to specify this
the plane you're using the center right
those are the four things you need to
know
okay cool looks looks nice
looks quite clean
great so then julian date is the time
that will be used fundamentally
so that's the standard because it's a
continuous counting of dates
yep and so it's very um
very nice and then
it will handle lip seconds etc
and so again julian date is a function
that we will start by
implementing time system there i wrote a
little page for time system so you see a
collection of the time systems i have in
mind
and this will all go with i mean in the
end this will go with astro graphics
which will then have high resolution
right exactly we are collecting lots of
data there are huge catalogs out there
with
objects so
yep
so the name of this is also a bit
confusing some people call it time scale
and others times standard i don't like
either of them
i think time system is a better version
better name
yeah this looks sensible right and there
for example you see the
the the b this is the time uh
at the solar system very center right
and the g is at the earth
right okay
question from epi does converting
between frames frequently
lose precision
um loose precision
well i mean because you don't know where
the center of the sun is or something i
don't think so i think it's pretty
precise
yeah i no i i don't foresee any
major issues precision there
yeah rotations are very well known
right and and i mean since a few decades
ago
there is this new international
celestial reference frame which is fully
fixed so so that has helped a lot
because until now all these frames were
moving the galactic
ecliptic etc they are all moving
what do you mean they're moving how are
they moving the
the ecliptic plane is moving and i mean
everything is rotating so
i mean the ecliptic coordinates what i'm
trying to say
so we are measuring the position of
things that are moving with respect to
frames that
are also moving yes and so you have to
specify
two dates and that's the the terminology
in astronomy is
the position of something at a given
date
with respect to this frame of this given
day
i see so the the use of
the international celestial frame
removes the date of the second one
because this now is truly i mean
to the best of our technology it's
stationary
microarch second position
by the way is is um oh it doesn't
already yet
but solar time what's the relationship
between solo time and local mean time
local mean time so solar time has these
uh first argument that we decided it was
an option we changed it to our first
argument
mean time so that's local mean time
okay and solar time it's about up to 15
minutes with respect to that right
because the sun
is sometimes moving faster moving slower
yep
due to electricity of the of the orbit
and the tilting
of the earth yep and so yeah the
examples for reduction
does that differ so that's a very
important difference it's called the
equation of time
and it's one of these things that is
traditionally written in the abstract
labs
the abstract labs have a curve for the
yes i remember i mean
is this the right way for us to present
the equation of time
i think so it's a these things are all
angles even though they are called times
they are actually angles
and the equation of time is is a is a
difference of two
yes we could have its own function but
it seems what is it it's solar time
minus
local time it's it's true solar time
minus mean solar time
okay so it's solar time open back close
bracket minus solar time
quotes mean exactly yeah i think it's
it's further down in applications
yeah that's because that looks like it
yeah
yeah and this is computed for i mean it
changes with the year
that's something that not everybody
realizes
and so we can compute it for thousands
of years
past i think i have examples further
down too
there's similar things for every planet
right yes indeed this curve is different
for for different planets
yep and are we going to support that
model arrow
geometry whatever yes eventually when we
have all the data needed
so this depends typically on three
angles or three numbers
the elliptic the eccentricity of the
orbit
the tilting and the very
very astron position of the orbit
okay
yes so sidereal time was also updated
to have both mean and true forms
and which also allows
describing mutation and then there is
this this very large function
which has control or reports all sorts
of properties about the motion of the
earth and eventually of other planets
so this is a function that will report
the differences of the different time
systems
it will know everything about lip
seconds etc
okay duration of the day
the the fact that the rotation of the
the rotation axis of the earth is moving
with respect to the earth
by a few meters and of course it's also
moving with respect to the
celestial frame that's the precision
annotation effects
something i don't know how to do is the
uncertainty
so the first example i think or the
second example shows the
the thing so
why don't we have an annotation a third
argument that asks for
you know that that can give either the
full around form
where it can give just the uncertainty
or you can give just
the central number i see
okay and that's what we do in the entity
framework seems like a reasonable way to
do it
okay so we just want the central number
right i like that so i think the if you
go a little bit further on
there is an example yes this one in
which we could return
yeah nice
so that's for a given day it tells you
the difference with respect to the 18
86 400 seconds
right but i think most of the time you
just like give me the best value
i'm happy right so i think a fourth
argument is a
third argument in this case is the right
thing um we need to wrap this meeting
because we have another one
coming right up uh but i just want to
oh boy okay
all things blocking that becoming
default
yes so our plan is to have vector maps
by defaulting 13.
right
yeah well so you're working through all
these things yep where okay
and ethan is asking about dynamic
geographics having vectors which will be
coming right
uh yes eventually yeah of course
okay um
yes so data set entries require their
own meetings
indeed they do yes and then uh around
yes we just wanted to mention that
around this is now for elementary
operations
is a lot faster as a result of
compilation yeah
it's a mixture of moving some things to
c and compilation indeed
okay cool very nice
all right i should we should we should
wrap up here and um
i know we have a different some of us
have a different meeting to get to
um great
well lots of nice stuff very nice stuff
the the astro thing
is actually going to be simpler than i
thought it would be um
i mean you know i think it's the all the
experience we have with all the geo
stuff probably helps
indeed and for a graphical part much of
the code could be
will be reused good
and we do we get vector i don't even
know what it means to have vector
uh astrographics that doesn't mean
anything well it does because most of
the
information is going to be points points
and lines for the constellations
of that yeah fair enough and then a
background we need just a
very good image of the background with
the galaxy etc
right that will be
wait a minute ethan is commenting that
previous comment about remote times
locations and time he says his
mathematica says his time is 5 p.m even
though it's 6 p.m
well it shouldn't how could it does it
well
if your computer doesn't know where you
are then you're out of luck
if if has mathematica been running since
before
the time change that's a good question
but i mean local time of here
better give you the oh boy
well for me here is a thousand miles
away
because of the way that my internet is
configured
right so that's confusing so it depends
on
what does it depend on what what is it
picking up dollar time zone
dollar time zone is reading the current
time zone offset provided by your
operating system
based on the oh no it is right it is
right up no it isn't right
it's 6 p.m right now where i am
oh but this is okay what is going on
here what is going on
what what i mean your location probably
is that of champagne
right because you are in the vpn of
champagne no
well but
time zone minus five what is here
that's champagne yeah right okay okay
okay so we have a dollar system time
zone which is the time zone reported by
the computer
and then dollar time zone can be reset
so if the user wants to
say dollar time zone goes to whatever
what the hell is that well that's that's
the one that we cannot change
that's the one look my computer is
saying 6 p.m
but well
i guess the question is does it change
when we when you are out of the vpn
i'm not in vpn or you are not in vpn
no yeah but i mean the setting of dollar
system time zone is not dependent on
your
dollar how can how can my clock up here
in the corner say 6 p.m
and my system time zone
is saying something which makes it which
corresponds to time
one hour different
you only have 94 you i presume this
session hasn't been active
since saturday right that's correct
as if it's
oh am i 12 2 i couldn't guarantee that
let me look at something yeah yeah if
you
isn't there a session time that tells
you how long the thing has been running
yes but let's just try here
oh yeah so this yeah so that previous
session
is a bugasaurus i mean yeah come on
what's going on there guys
i mean i admit that's a very corner case
yeah it's
it's a corner case that is enshrined in
some legacy behavior and it's why we
want to migrate away from strict numeric
time zones to
modern time zones but one of the issues
okay so so basically
that should at least be impossible
issues in the documentation
not that anyone will ever notice it but
um it will happen
once or twice a year that you start your
session time zone transitions and your
session
doesn't get tickled to say oh my time
zone's changed so
this also happens to drive your location
if you
move it doesn't change just yes i
understand
right right it's a possible issue it's
not necessarily a design
problem but it's something that with
using modern time zones we
you don't run into it okay so ethan
is it's on the island of
dominica okay so let's just see what
happens if i say
sounds like an interesting place a bit
of a dominica
okay and now i say local time
says 6 pm
so i'm totally confused let's try we
could try in the existing version
that was a very annoying bug
so 6 p.m i'm confused
so 6 p.m oh no this is my version that's
been running since
whenever suggesting there might be a bug
in right one last thing to debug and
then we need to go to another meeting
just waiting for the thing to be you
know to base its
time on on a satellite internet thing
where it thinks that you're at some
astral position
well this is right too so i'm confused i
don't know what's wrong
okay sorry send in send in a bug report
if there's something going on
ethan
okay um got to run thanks guys